[Music]
it is being sent through the ages
without sacrifice there could be no
victory to species at war one flesh one
methyl
Optimus Prime has left us 100 billion
trillion planets in the cosmos
[Music]
you want to know don't you lay why they
keep coming here
on a stay
and I want to fight them
now two worlds colliding
the operations over we're not giving up
a paper
only one survives
oh my god
forgive me
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie so if you're
wondering what's going on there's
transformers in the time of King Arthur
I'll totally explain it's called the
last night but the film mostly takes
place in present day I've also got some
news about the spider-man homecoming
trailer that I'll explain at the end of
this but there's a whole bunch of
happening this week with a bunch of
midseason finales for the comic book TV
shows so be sure to subscribe to get
everything and make sure you enable
alerts so you don't miss any of the
videos with that right there looks like
some hardcore Optimus Prime on bumblebee
violence and I know that people are
wondering like is that Unicron so they
invited a whole bunch of websites to the
film set to learn things about the film
about as much fun as you can have making
movies
like a follower
open up this not between her hat she's
home and I'm out in a car at 100 miles
an hour in front of her house
I'm not English but I don't know if this
problem
[Applause]
[Music]
great show
very excited
blast shooting is movie
to wrap everybody they've changed the
way that they make transformer films
they have like a story group now and
they're trying to write more from the
pre-existing mythology so like if you
watch the classic cartoons Gen one all
through the series up to now you'll
probably see a lot of Easter eggs but
they did say the villain of this movie
is something different that they haven't
done before like the last couple of
villains have all been relatively
comparable to Optimus Prime just
different leader versions of transformer
Decepticon transformers so it feels like
they're getting closer to Unicron
territory or whatever it is the builders
race that Optimus Prime went after in
the last movie so it sounds like what
they did is they had an idea for a movie
follow up to miss Prime's mission to go
fight the builders but then combined it
with a little more fantasy so you see
flashbacks to King Arthur and his
Knights so the idea of the last night
just kind of spreads across the entire
film like Optimus Prime is one of the
last nights King Arthur in his Knights
you see they brought back Josh Duhamel
he wasn't in the last film I was like
Mark Wahlberg's big entry into the
franchise so they're teaming up then
this actress Laura haddock is basically
like the new female protagonist of the
film she's this English character that's
really important to saving the earth but
doesn't really understand how that works
so she's part of the mythology they
wouldn't really reveal how that's going
to work but she might just have like a
genetic link to King Arthur that has
something to do with defeating the
villain of the film they also confirmed
that Grimlock is coming back so we'll
have some Dinobots he's gonna wreck the
[ __ ] out of a bunch of stuff but Anthony
Hopkins was probably the biggest
surprise for me I knew he was going to
be in the film but it's so funny that
they dropped this right after the
west-world finale so it sounds like a
lot of the mythology the fantasy
elements of the film will flow from his
character in present-day
but this new transformer is called
squeaks he kind of partners up with this
girl here they're two of the new
protagonists so another really cool
transformer that's debuting is a
submarine transformer that just looks
like a giant octopus is pretty badass in
they D confirm that they will explore
the history of the primes like Optimus
Prime is just the latest prime in a line
of primes so you see them floating here
in outer space that's just him in the
wake of what happened after the last
film left
so something really terrible happens he
hits a low point has to decide whether
or not he wants to continue being a
leader but you see the bumblebee fight
there might be a fight for the
leadership matrix which makes me think
of the original transformers movie that
was all about the leadership matrix to
feeding Unicron so it would be really
cool if they included him in a film in
their doing ego the Living Planet and
guardians of the galaxy so giant planet
sized villains aren't off the table as
long as you do them in a really cool way
this might be Megatron but he typically
doesn't use a sword so it might be one
of the other new Transformers usually
Megatron changes more than the other
characters like they don't change
Optimus Prime that much they just give
him some more cool toys to play with
like last time he got the sword but he
doesn't have the classic red coloring
here so this is definitely not Optimus
Prime but let me know what you guys
think of the trailer you know generally
I think of the transformer franchise
it's just like fun popcorn pulpy action
films something you like you know pretty
much what you're getting when you go
into it so I think it's interesting that
they're trying to introduce some fantasy
elements to this and I haven't really
been keeping up a lot with the animated
series since like the first couple
generations like one of the last big
series that I watched on a regular basis
was beast wars and that was a long time
ago
so if you guys are like big fans of the
Transformers series right now you guys
can let me know what you think of this
or if you haven't watched in a long time
but fun fact Michael Bay shot this movie
on almost the exact same type of camera
that James Gunn shot guardians of the
galaxy to want it's a new version of the
red weapon helium 8 case sensor so if
any of you guys are camera geeks both of
them got slightly different variations
of the same red weapon helium camera
just tweaked a little bit in different
ways to suit the different types of
scenes they shoot like Michael Bay James
Gunn shoot very different types of films
so even though it's the same camera you
just have to set them up in slightly
different ways but I just love the idea
of Dragon transformers in the time of
King Arthur it just makes you think of
game of robot Thrones or something like
that
this is just the first trailer so we
don't learn about the actual story of
the film you just you see like this
giant planet size transformer looking
like it's coming to eat the earth
Unicron style so you can kind of guess
that they have to stop that but whatever
the main action of the film is the
Decepticons are always a big problem so
there's always like small boss fights
then you have like the big boss fight
which they kind of tease with like that
end roll into the text where you're like
inside the giant robot then you come out
that's just why I keep thinking of
Unicron you still kind of have to
address the end of the last film with
Optimus Prime going after the creators
so this just might be the creator's
pushing back but the producers have been
teasing a new type of mystery villain so
it might not be the creator's otherwise
I think they would have just said that
like oh the people that Optimus Prime
went to stop they're coming for us now
so that kind of confirms that it's going
to be somebody totally different but
usually like the second the third
trailer are more story based trailers so
they give you a better idea of why we go
to all these different time periods why
it's important it probably just provides
lineage to the new female protagonist
Anthony Hopkins character they probably
give us our link to the fantasy elements
the King Arthur period during the film
but spider-man homecoming trailer news
so it turns out that there was like some
fake stuff going around the other day
that people tried to discredit so
apparently there's no spider-man
homecoming trailer but then the agents
of shield actors were teasing that they
had a special teaser after the midseason
finale Tuesday night so there is some
special trailer that's going to air but
most people feel like it's going to be
something different for the Marvel
Universe something from the TBS or the
movies but there is some sort of special
trailer after agents of shield so
whatever it is I'll totally do a video
for it but the flash versus Savitt are
with Jay Garrick midseason finale is
tomorrow night too so there's a whole
bunch of comic book stuff happening so
we'll try and get those videos out as
fast as possible but I'm just so happy
that all this stuff is dropping right
now it's gonna be awesome while you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
to re-watch the guardians 2 trailer and
you can click here for my Westworld
finale video thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you